What is up, guys? In today's video, I'm
going be showing you five money makers
for mid levels with using combat. These
may not be your personal favorite mid
levels. You may think some mid-level
combat methods are better, but these are
my personal favorite, the ones that I
think work the best for making money
while being a mid-level. So, just keep
that in mind. And also, these are not in
really any particular order. They're
just in the order of my least favorite
to my favorite. So, keep that in mind.
All right, let's get started in the
video, guys. Throughout the whole video,
my combat level is 89 and my stats are
70 attack, 71 strength, 70 defense, 86
range, 52 prayer, and 76 magic. Let's
get started into the first money-making
method. The first method is killing
Brian rats. So, this is the equipment
I'm bringing. Also, keep in mind, I
bring the Draymond staff, so make sure
you do the fairy rings quest so you can
get that teleport there. And then bring
a speck web, super attack, super
strength, bring a spade. Do not forget
the spade. Bring any fish or food you
want to bring. Bring the Draymond staff
or the teleport. And then bring bones to
peaches if you are lower level. So
whenever you get their bones, you can
turn them into bones. You also need to
start the Olaf's quest to get here to be
able to use this spot. And then I am
using the teleport DKS to get to that
area. So go ahead and teleport here.
And then run up to this spot by this
tree.
Go ahead and dig with a spade.
Run up to this area where the brine rats
are.
Once you get here, start to drink your
super strength and super attack.
get your spec weap out and then go ahead
and start. They are level 70. They're
very weak. Some of their drops are raw
sharks noted, raw pikes, noted, a few
other raw fish noted, and then they also
drop the brine saber, which makes it
worth a lot more money. So, you can get
some pretty good combat XP here. And
then you can also make anywhere from
100k to 500k an hour if you're getting
some good drops. The next method is
something you're probably familiar with.
It's killing blue dragons. And this is
the equipment I wear. I am using adamant
bolts because it is quicker to kill him
with that. And make sure you bring your
anti- fire shield. And then I am
bringing two tunas just in case. A
ranging potion too, a stamina potion
too, a dusty key and a fidor teleport.
If you do not know where to get the
dusty key, I am sure there are guides
online, but just follow this path that I
take to get to the blue dragons.
[Music]
Hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey.
Once you are here, run into this corner
and then start killing the blue dragon.
So, the notable drops from blue dragons
is they always drop blue dragon hide and
dragon bones. And then they also can
drop random alco items. They also can
drop nature runes and also can drop
other things such as clue scrolls and a
few other items. You can make a
guaranteed 400k to 600k here an hour and
you get some pretty decent range XP. The
next method is attacking a very low
requirement boss and that is the KBD or
king black dragon. And this is my setup.
I am using the diamond bolts E. And then
this is also the gear you want to bring.
You want to bring a ranging pot, three
prayer pots, so you can use eagle eye or
pray against him antidote and an
extended anti-fire, monkfish, and a
burning amulet.
And make sure you only bring what you're
willing to lose. As we are going into
the wilderness,
this is how you get to the King Black
Dragon. You teleport to the lava maze.
[Music]
And then you run up here.
Go ahead and go and open this gate.
And then go ahead and climb down the
ladder.
And then pull the lever and you'll go to
the King Black Dragon. Now, a lot of
times people are already in the lair, so
go ahead and hop to an empty world. Once
you get an empty world, go ahead and run
over here into the center where King
Black Dragon is. Drink your anti-fire,
your antidote, your ranging potion, and
then you can either attack him from far
away or get close to him and pray melee
while also praying eagle-eye. The reason
why I suggest you do this is because he
will hit you with melee at least one
time. So that way you will always be
blocking at least one of his attacks.
Otherwise, you can just back away from
him and attack him from a distance. You
can also duo King Black Dragon, which is
a method that I suggest you do, and you
just split your drops. It's not that
hard to do, but you just need two people
to do it. The notable drops, I will put
them on screen because there's a lot of
them, but the most obvious ones are it
always drops two black dragon heights
and dragon bones. So, make sure to pick
that up. And then uoggs, it drops 150 of
them at a time, noted. So, that's an
easy 48k. also can drop very rarely a
king black dragon pet, a king black
dragon head, and then it can also drop a
dragon pickaxe or a draconic visage,
which are very valuable items, so you
can make loads of money. This method is
super easy to do, especially if you duo
it. But if you do it alone, you can
easily make 400k an hour. And then if
you get a lucky drop, it's going to be
anywhere between 400k to 1 mil an hour.
And you also get loads of range XP. The
next method is killing a somewhat new
monster in the wilderness. We are
killing revenants. This is the gear
setup I choose and I recommend. Make
sure to have the bracelet of ethereum
charged, the glory. I brought an archers
ring and a toxic blowpipe because you
cannot lose more than three items. I'm
bringing a raging potion, prayer
potions, stamina potion, sharks, kambbo
so I can stack eat, and a burning
amulet. And the rest is monkfish. So go
ahead and teleport to the lava maze. And
you are going to the wilderness. So if
you see white dots, make sure to log out
and then go ahead and switch worlds
until you find an empty one. Once you
find an empty world, go ahead and follow
this path.
Once you enter the cave, go ahead and
run down here.
And then always be ready to log out
because you never know if a TMP carriers
is here as it is a multi-combat area.
And then I like to run down here in this
area cuz the lower level revenants are
down here. drink your ranging potion and
then go ahead and start attacking them.
With the bracelet of athereum, you will
not take any damage. So, it's a very
good method. And then also pray
eagle-eye. So, the notable drops will be
on screen. They drop loads of dragon
items, loads of rune items, and then
they drop onyx bolt tips, runey bolts,
dragon bolt tips. They can drop sharks
noted, mana rays, noted, ye logs, noted,
magic logs, noted, adamant bars, black
dragon hide, and then a few other items.
The most significant items they can drop
is the ancient crystal, the ancient
emblem, ancient totem, and the ancient
statueette. They also have a chance of
dropping the mysterious emblem. The
coolest part about revenants is that any
level revenant. No matter the level,
they all drop the same items. The higher
ones have a higher chance of dropping
the better items though. And also,
occasionally, a very rare roll can be
performed which multiplies specific
drops by 100. That means that you can
times any of the rewards times 100 and
you can get that drop. That is worth
loads of money. You can make any amount
of money. The amount of money that
you'll be making from revenants is
anywhere from 500k to 1 mil plus because
you really do not know which drops you
will get, but it's always a consistent
500k an hour. The final method is my
personal favorite is doing barrows. This
is the setup I am using. I am using a
Sears ring, book of darkness, peaceful
blessing, a cult necklace, trident of
the seas, and a combat bracelet. And I'm
using arrows. And then my switch into my
range gear is this.
There's a lot of guides on barrel, so if
you want an in-depth guide, go ahead and
look it up. But make sure to bring a
blowpipe, all of your range switch gear,
and then bring a spade, a ranging
potion, monkfish, three prayer pots, a
ring of dueling, barrels teleports, and
a stamina potion.
And then go ahead and teleport to
barrows, and begin your Barrows trip.
[Music]
Hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey.
[Music]
Once you get downstairs, go ahead and
check which door that you can open and
then go ahead and kill three skeletons
and get ready to open the chest.
Hey.
Once you open the final door, then you
will open the chest and you will get
your items. The notable drops from
Barrows is you will always get something
from the chest. You can get blood runes,
chaos runes, death runes, and mine
runes. And you can also get coins, parts
of keys, and then the most significant
items you can get is all of the barrels
pieces. Doing barrels will always get
you a consistent 600k per hour, but you
can easily make 1 mil plus an hour. All
right, guys. That is the end of this
video. I hope you find it helpful. If
you do find it helpful, go ahead and
leave me a like. If you have some other
methods that you think are just as good,
go ahead and leave it in the comment
section. If you have any ideas for
videos, go ahead and leave it in the
comment section. As always, if you're
new to the channel, go ahead and
subscribe. And thanks for watching guys.
Stay tuned for my next video.